wann kommt rein wir haben heute einiges
vor wir wollen die hühner füttern die
tränke saubermachen die nets boxen
saubermachen die ziegen füttern und den
stall ausmisten da nehme ich euch auf
jeden fall immer mit dann könnt ihr mich
mal durch meinen alltag begleiten und an
der arbeit habe ich auch verschiedene
besprechungen für neue kohle die wehr
stellen und neue projekte die wir haben
die auch ganz aufregend sehen da freue
ich mich auf jeden fall auch schon euch
mal mit zunehmend euch zu zeigen was
alles im hintergrund passieren muss
damit so ein garten block läuft und
damit die kurse laufen das ist nämlich
nicht so dass ich das alles alleine
gruppe das würde ich überhaupt nicht
schaffen dann zeige ich euch mal werde
als noch so mitmacht falls du mich noch
nicht kennst und ich frage von was redet
die marie denn da was für nur arbeit und
du hast schöne garten blog ist das denn
ich habe einen garten block der heißt
wurzelwerk punkt nett da schreibe ich
über themen rund um die selbstversorgung
aus dem garten kinder bekommen zum
frühstück dick gewonnene milch und alte
brotkrumen unseren lecker und schloss
aus allem möglichen was wir nicht mehr
helfen wollen
guten appetit es ist echt eine tolle
möglichkeit besten sorgenkinder sind
ungefähr genauso wie schweine die
fressen fast alles seid ihr nicht zu süß
zu salzig und zu fettig sein habe ich
mich bist gut ja unter wasser einige von
euch haben sich gewünscht dass ich mal
unseren hühnerstall vorführen aber das
ist billiger fertig stellen die ihnen
wir jetzt schon sicher dreimal
zusammenflicken mussten weil er komplett
auseinander gekracht ist also den kann
ich absolut nicht empfehlen ich bin
dabei einen neuen stall zu planen den
wir selber bauen wollen der dann alle
features hat die man sich so wünschen
kann schubladen um den mist rauszuziehen
genug platz für die hühner zum nisten
aber den kann ich absolut nicht
empfehlen und ich hab auch noch von
keinem fertig stein gehört der irgendwie
was taugen würde wenn ihr eine
empfehlung habt schreibt es gerne in die
kommentare
aber wir haben an dem ding schon soviel
herumgedoktert dass wir in der zeit
locker unseren eigenen stall hätten
bekommen können und die die teile sind
schon kaputt angekommen in der falschen
farbe wirklich schrott kann
sagen dass sie sind die nets boxen
schaut euch das an
das ist von der rasse die heisst marin
und die machen wunderschöne ja die
können noch viel viel dunkler sein
wodurch die dunkelrote eierlegen gibt
zum teil es ist super super hübsch auf
jeden fall ist es immer gut die nas
boxen sauber zu halten weil dann auch
die eier sauber bleiben und es ist mal
wieder an der zeit die einstreu zu
wechseln
hier haben wir noch so ein paar fake wie
lege ich immer mit in den s box damit
die schüler wissen dass sie da ihre eier
liegen können weil sonst können die die
auch überall im ganzen garten verteilt
legen und dann ist jeden tag ostermann
versuchte zusammen
[Musik]
wenn das nicht ein und aussieht was
richtig ist
ganz viele eier zu legen oder könnte man
sollte gleich mal ausprobieren
pocahontas und der index petunia und die
das geld der garten die haben insgesamt
acht stück auf dem schirm für meinen
sohn jedes mal wenn er in den hosen oder
jackentasche transportiert aber diesmal
ist der blick gut gegangen
denn die zahl der war die immer und dann
greift man in so einen schleim kann man
sich die hände in die taschen steckt
[Musik]
die eier schreiben kann man den knien
lieblingsoper wiedergeben nichts drückt
die einfach gemacht
die aufpicken können und dass sie auch
nicht mehr als eier schalen erkennbar
sind bei den wiener sollen ja nicht
länger zufrieden
[Musik]
nächste aufgabe
ich hatte gerade im büro einer
besprechung mit jackie meiner
mitarbeiterinnen die alle von euch den
gemüsegarten staaten meinem online kurs
mit dabei sind oder auch in obst und
gemüse haltbar machen
die kennt ihr natürlich alle jackie ist
die dir mal die e mails beantwortet die
ganze in den facebook gruppen auch aktiv
ist und ihr euch bei euren fragen
weiterhilft und jackie hat noch lieber
jetzigen gesehen und ich habe mir gerade
erzählt daß ich empfehlen möchte wie wir
heute den stall ausmisten und sie möchte
mit kommend hätten also werdet ihr die
jetzt auch gleich mal ein bisschen
besser kennenlernen könnte auskochen
springer ag das normalerweise nicht ich
hab die nicht eingestellt hat sich mainz
ins toraus mit euren fragen und im neuen
garten und bin immer auf facebook aktiv
unbeantwortet
zwar spart zum größten teil aus ja ich
freue mich total darauf dass ich die
entwicklung neuer unglaublich viel spaß
ihr seid so so fleißig jetzt echt der
wahnsinn und ihr motivierten mich auch
immer wieder gleich habe ich luft im
garten zu gehen und weiterzuarbeiten
vielen lieben dank dafür alle die in den
kursen mit dabei sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
geschafft doch stand hier jemand
äußersten fall wird mit dem kopf gegen
die strecke geräumt
[Musik]
hier ist eigentlich der wahnsinn wie
sich das alles entwickelt hat mit dem
blog ich habe das als reines hobby
angefangen ab und zu mal was ins
internet geschrieben über die sachen die
ich im garten neu gelernt habe und die
sachen die ich zu hause ausprobiert habe
gedacht könnte irgendwie weiterhelfen
vor allem habe ich das aber gemacht weil
ich den ganzen tag über sachen reden
könnte und wir irgendwann niemals zu
hören wollte und dann habe ich
angefangen sind blog zu schreiben und
irgendwann ist es so durch die decke
gegangen hatte ich zum ersten mal 50.000
auf wofür im monat jetzt sind es eine
halbe million auch wofür im monat
und es ist so so schön dass es
mittlerweile mein beruf geworden ist es
hat sich irgendwie sehr schleichend
entwickelt also ich habe auch erst seit
anderthalb jahren mitarbeiter und die
haben irgendwann war halt einfach klar
ich arbeite so viel ich arbeite rund um
die uhr und es gibt einige sachen die
ich super gut abgeben könnte und da habe
ich angefangen mir zum ersten mal hilfe
zu suchen
auch erstmal nicht so die tollsten leute
in meinem team gehabt so dass ich mich
danach wieder von einigen
mittlerweile haben wir so ein
unglaublich tolles team also das passt
einfach alles perfekt wir haben es immer
so lustig über einem kleinen wurzelwerk
büro und ich erzähle ich werde alles
somit macht also jackie kennen
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch
lieber in kurven mittlerweise die hat an
der gleichen uni wo ich auch studiere
ihren master gemacht und die hat den
über das gärtnern ohne umgraben und über
die bodenlebewesen geschrieben also
genau mein thema und fast einfach wie
die faust aufs auge lösung ohne jack wie
würde wirklich bei wurzelwerk nicht
ansatzweise so viel gehen wie wie sie im
moment möglich ist und ich bin ihr so
dankbar
und ja dann haben wir noch kilian der
kümmert sich um die technische seite
also der welt -artikel hoch in wordpress
auf meine website damit die dann auch
zum richtigen zeitpunkt online gehen die
bilder ein
wenn ich den größe was die überschriften
betreut main-post account der let you
tube videos hoch damit die dann auch
rechtzeitig online gehen und macht ganz
viel hinter den kulissen was so die
technische seite angeht also ich kann
echt nur sagen und so unglaublich
glücklich dass ich diese unterstützung
habe und ja das irgendwie ermöglicht
habe den ganzen tag wird gerne zu reden
und das ist meine arbeit ist es
unglaublich ich bin wirklich mega mega
happy dass mir das ermöglicht haben
danke schlink und dann kombinat hager
kümmert sich um alles ist also
buchhaltung und steuern nach hacks auf
meine chance kommt mir genauso franziska
die schneidet die ganzen videos macht
ihr auch super toll das ist die einzige
die jetzt nicht hier vor ort montiert
ein bisschen weiter weg und dann habe
ich schon erzählt aber es war aber nicht
erzählt sven macht gerade ein praktikum
den studierte ökologische landwirtschaft
und da muss man immer vier monate
berufspraktikum machen und das macht er
gerade
bei uns decke man sich auch ganz viele
technische sachen und pdf design und
kleine grafiken erstellt werden müssen
und unterstützt mich da so dass ich
durch mein team die möglichkeit habe vor
der kamera zu stehen für euch inhalte zu
erstellen und daher den rücken
freigehalten bekomme und das ist
supertoll also macht einfach richtig
bock ich dir jeden morgen auf und habt
so lust auf meine arbeit und arbeite mit
tollen leuten zu unserem essen perfekt
wir bauen wir uns noch einen
jungpflanzen regale an ich mache meine
jungen pflanzen anzucht immer in einem
regal wo ich dann in den einzeln in
italien immer jeweils eine pflanzen
lampe aufhängen kann bisher habe ich das
regal noch gar nicht aufgebaut und wo
ich schon lange mit der anzucht
angefangen habe haben wir so
provisorisch unter einer lampe im bad
ihr talent ihr zusammengequetscht aber
es wird zu eng und ich habe vor heute
auch noch einige pflanzen vorzuziehen so
dass wir dringend dieses regal brauchen
und mein freund gesund und hilft mir
dabei das auszubauen obwohl es ihnen
jetzt im angriff wieder über den
stellenwert aber was machen dem
gewächshaus unsere momenten zu kalt die
tage sind noch zu kurz im gewächshaus
ziehe ich dann immer erst ab april vor
das hat sich bei uns so bewährt dass wir
das so früh um ja noch im haus machen
damit kommt der richtung ich bezahle
ihnen ja auch in sehr leckere gemüse
haben sie einen muskel
[Musik]
ich meine steuerung der papa nicht will
ist das regal hier steht fest so
schrecklich leuchtet da ich war in den
letzten zwei wochen richtig krank und
hab ihn im bett gelegen und deswegen
sind einige ausfahrten auf der strecke
geblieben die ich jemand hervor und
machen wollte da was sie also einiges
nachholen ich selber nachdem maria ton
kalender aus und jetzt ist blood tag
deswegen werden wir heute die ganzen
blattgemüse aussehen ja jetzt kann es
richtig losgehen weil das tanzen regal
endlich steht es anzucht regal
also werde ich dir jetzt alle aussehen
ich sehe die erstmal eine kleine
schälchen und pc die dann in einzelne
töpfchen sobald sie aufgegangen sind
außerdem darf er bleibt bisher aus
gepflanzt wird in den kleinen schälchen
unter einem der letzten videos habt ihr
kommentiert dass ihr so komisch findet
dass ich erst ein video machen wo ich
zeige wie man plastik bei der anzucht
vermeidet und zeigen den eigenen pflanzt
tütchen aus klopapierrollen usw selber
was das kann ich euch gerne hier um
verlinken wenn ihr das anschauen möchte
und im nächsten video nämlich wieder
kräftig ab das liegt einfach daran dass
ich noch ganz ganz viele plastik
töpfchen habe ich natürlich noch so
lange weiter verwenden wie sie noch
irgendwie zusammen halten auch wenn ich
kräuter irgendwo kaufen dann kriegt
meine augen immer ein tröpfchen und die
recycelt
einfach immer wieder was ich auch super
wichtig findet bei der anzucht ist
welche markiert was man da überhaupt
kein geld hat am anfang hab ich immer
mache ich kann mir das auf jeden fall
merken was in welchem team wächst aber
pustekuchen nach zwei monaten überhaupt
keine ahnung was da wächst und gerade
die ganzen kleinen pflänzchen die lassen
sich im jungpflanzen stadium so schwer
auseinanderhalten dass ich immer kleine
labels schreiben sie mir auf schreibe
was das ist weil wir die sorte heißt und
wie viele exemplare ich davon in welchem
boot später pflanzen möchte so dass ich
immer einen guten überblick habe was ich
denn jetzt schon vorgezogen habe was
noch kommen muss und später auch weiß
für welche speed waren diese pflanzen
überhaupt gedacht ursprünglich
[Musik]
das hier ist ein lauf den habe ich beim
sex video kanal entdeckt und dann
scheiden sich großbild und den ich
dieses jahr zum ersten mal an bauen
werde und schon sehr gespannt habt ihr
den schon mal angebaut können das gar
nicht aussprechen
ich freue mich auf jeden fall ich freue
mich generell immer so immer so an
krebsfällen immer ganz angelegt sind
die selber mal auszuprobieren
[Musik]
also ich glaub eher langweiligen
papierkram machen für die steuer und die
krankenkassen bei der mitarbeiter so
weit da was man da alles machen muss
wenn man einen betrieb hat papa papa ich
suche übrigens im moment noch jemanden
der mir mit e mails hilft für mein team
wurzeln also wenn da jemand von euch
lust hat muss jemand sein der sich mit
gemüse richtig gut auskennt und wer
richtig platz blut für hat und ab lust
hat anfängern weiter zu helfen oft nur
konstruktive motivierende liebevolle art
und weise schreibt mir gerne e-mails
sende euch hier mal die adresse einer
könnt ihr euch gerne bewerben ich freue
mich auf jeden fall richtig wenn ich da
jemanden aus der community finde der
vielleicht mit wurzelwerk schon
vertrauter ist oder auch mit dem garten
system
ihr müsstet nicht hier vor ort wohnen
das wäre natürlich perfekt ich bin das
immer viel schöner wenn man sich
zusammen an einen tisch setzen kann
zumindest ab und zu meine mitarbeiter
arbeiten noch viel von zu hause aus aber
es geht genauso gut auch wenn natürlich
das remote sie kennen wird auch vom bett
im home office arbeiten
das ist ein ganz spät man sich schon im
bett und ich setze mich an das buch das
ich gerade schreibe das schreibe ich
diesen zahlen verlage es geht um
selbstversorgung zu fliegen und den
gemüsegarten das haltbarmachen der ernte
brotbacken und so weiter und das macht
so viel spaß an dem buch zu schreiben
ich finde es ein bisschen schade dass
ich nicht so oft dazu kommen im moment
aber wenn alles gut geht dann erscheint
das im frühjahr 2021 also zur nächsten
garten gesundes dauert ihren büchern ist
irgendwann erscheint mir gar nicht
vorstellen dass uns irgendwann mal in
den hinten halten ist sicher toll schmid
nein ich freue mich schon richtig darauf
in das problem endlich fertig
[Musik]
das recht erhalten